Weil es darin unter anderem Privacy geht, aber auch im Porn, also um das Internet.
Na dann, hören wir mal rein. Norfix mit Vanilla Sex auf besonderen Wunsch eines Gastes hier im Chaosradio in Blue Moon. Und das wäre natürlich nicht dasselbe, das Chaosradio in Blue Moon ohne die Nerd News, geschrieben vom Chaos Computer Club, präsentiert von Scarlett Kubosik.
Die sogenannte Logjam-Lücke erlaubt es Angreifern, sichere Netzverbindungen zu belauschen und zu manipulieren. Durch diese Lücke lassen sich nämlich Server durch Dritte dazu überreden, schwache Kryptographie zu verwenden, die sich dann einfach knacken lässt. Die Browser-Hersteller arbeiten derzeit an Updates, Microsoft hat den Internet Explorer bereits aktualisiert. Grundlage für die Sicherheitslücke ist veralteter Programm-Code aus den 90er Jahren, der in vielen Servern immer noch verwendet wird. Experten raten deswegen Serverbetreibern dazu, diese Export-Zeifer abzuschalten. Eine neue Malware attackiert Router, die kleinen Plastikkästchen, die bei euch zu Hause das Internet in der Wohnung verteilen. Neu ist dabei, dass die Shard-Software in der Lage ist, über 50 Modelle fast aller großen Hersteller anzugreifen. Bei den befallenen Routern wird der komplette Internetverkehr umgeleitet oder verändert. Man fängt sich dieser Shard-Software ganz einfach ein, auf entsprechend präparierten Webseiten, versucht die Malware das Modell des Routers herauszufinden und attackiert es gezielt. Findet sie dabei keine Schwachstelle, probiert sie noch das Passwort durch raten herauszufinden. Deshalb gilt immer schön updaten und sichere Passwörter verwenden. Auf den Namen TOX hört ein neuer Dienst, mit dem sicher ein Erpressertrojaner bauen und ihn personalisieren und versenden lassen kann. Möchte gern Erpresser, können beliebigen Leuten einen angepassten Trojaner zusenden lassen, inklusive persönlicher Nachricht. Wird der Trojaner aktiviert, verschlüsselt dieser wichtige Dokumente auf dem Rechner der Opfer. Für die Freigabe der Daten wird eine Zahlung per Bitcoin an die Toxmacher verlangt. Diese behalten davon 30 Prozent für ihre Dienstleistung ein. Der Rest soll angeblich anonym an den Auftraggeber gehen. Besonders perfide, da die Schadsoftware jedes Mal neu verfasst wird, wird sie von Virenscannern und anderer Sicherheitssoftware kaum entdeckt.
Scarlet Kubosik präsentierte die Nerd News vom Chaos Computer Club. Und falls jetzt jemand zur letzten Meldung sagen will, wie könnt ihr es nur wagen, so was den Hörern vorzuschlagen, das ist als Sicherheitswarnung gedacht, nicht als Leitfaden. Ich hoffe, das ist klar. Und damit herzlich willkommen zurück zum Chaosradio im Blue Moon hier auf Fritz, wo wir heute über Snowden reden. Seit zwei Jahren gibt es die Leaks und wir reden ein bisschen darüber, wie es so war, was die Konsequenzen daraus sind und was man daraus vielleicht lernen kann. Zur Gast sind heute Anne Roth, sie arbeitet als Referentin für Die Linke beim NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo.
Andre Meister von netzpolitik.org. Hallo und guten Abend.
Und Linus Neumann vom Chaos Computer Club. Und wir haben jetzt sozusagen schon die Historie beleuchtet und haben ein bisschen über die Technik geredet, also die technischen Änderungen, die sich heraus ergeben, und wollen dann gleich zur politischen Aufarbeitung schreiben, die wir international schon ein bisschen beleuchtet hatten. Vorher aber haben wir noch Fabian hier in der Leitung, der angerufen hat, konnte er auch noch gerne machen, unter 0331 77 97 120, der was erzählen wollte dazu, wie es in seinem Umfeld die Reaktionen auf Snowden waren. Hallo und guten Abend, Fabian.
Du hast ganz am Anfang gefragt, wie ist denn, also deswegen habe ich da gedacht, ob ich das fragen kann. Das ist in meinem Umfeld eigentlich nicht unspektakulär gewesen, direkt nach Snowden, weil ich in verschiedenen Bubbles unterwegs bin. Und zum einen ist da die Bubble Stuttgarter Bahnhofswiderstand. Dann haben wir da die Bubble, ich bin selbstständig und habe Kunden, die in der Industrie arbeiten und in großen Firmen, renommierten Firmen. Und ich habe dann mein normales soziales Umfeld auf dem Dorf. Und spannend, oder was ich immer nicht mitteilen wollte, warum mache ich das gar nicht mehr, ist eigentlich, die allererste Reaktion auf dem Dorf ist, ja und aber Griechenland.
Das ist ja eine relativ aktuelle Diskussion. Am Anfang hat dir das gar nicht interessiert, oder wie?
Meine Analyse ist eigentlich, das befordert die Leute. Mich ja eigentlich auch, ich ringe hier am Chaos Computer Group Radio und fahre von einem ins Letzte mit dem anderen. Ich habe mir das letzte halbe Jahr sämtliche online stehenden Podcasts angehört. Den einen intensiver, den anderen weniger. Und habe dann auch mich entschieden, ich gehe jetzt machen ja ein Auf-Globe-PG und juckele da jetzt mit meinen zwei im Kurs, ich habe eigentlich keinen Sinn, also ich finde einfach keinen, der mit mir zum Schlüssel. Ich versuche aus der ganzen Zeit WhatsApp aufzulösen. Also meine Firma zum Beispiel wird dann automatisch von den Kunden teilweise angeschrieben per Shortmessage. Und bisher hatte man eben WhatsApp. Und ich habe es großartig angekündigt, ich verlängere das nicht mehr. Ich kille das aus, Schlussende vorbei. Und die Reaktion ist, sie schicken es dann halt per SMS anstatt per E-Mail. Oder irgendeine andere Alternative zu nehmen. Wo ich mir dann gedacht habe, das hat es jetzt nicht gebracht. Dann hätten wir auch bei WhatsApp bleiben können sozusagen. Bei meiner Adresse, die ja sowieso am eingestellt haben. Ich glaube, dass da in meinem Umfeld das ganze Komplex eigentlich gar nicht bekannt ist. Und wenn man jetzt zum Snowden spricht, ist man, wie vorher in euren Gesprächen ja schon rausgekommen, ist ja gleich auf einer ganz anderen Ebene, die einem persönlich gar nichts mehr angeht. Wenn man jetzt nicht der Aktivist ist, dann geht einem das eigentlich gar nichts an. Dann ist das so was wie Volkszählen. Und wenn ich das damit vergleiche, in meinem persönlichen direkten Umfeld, die Nummer mit Volkszählen, dann hat man ganz viele andere Probleme. Also dann ist es irgendwie wichtiger, was mit dem Euro passiert, und dann ist irgendwie wichtiger die Elbphilharmonie oder whatever. Das sind dann noch Steuergelder, wo die Menschen der Meinung sind, dass das ihr Geld mal war oder ist. Und das finden wir dann im Endeffekt wichtiger. Also ich habe in meinem persönlichen Umfeld niemanden, nicht einen einzigen, davon Bezug gekriegt WhatsApp zu verlassen, aus den bekannten Gründen. Ich müsste sie ja alle mitnehmen und dann zuteilen sie sich und dann habe ich sie nicht mehr.
Also sagen wir bei dir auch eher ein resigniertes Fazit aus dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Du rennst so gegen eine Wand.
Du rennst so gegen eine Wissenswand.
Das kriegst du ja gar nicht.
Das bringt uns ja genau wieder dazu, dass wir eigentlich mal auch darüber reden müssten, wie man es politisch macht. Weil, sagen wir, wir haben schon festgestellt, also technisch geht es sowieso nicht ganz. Inhaltlich funktioniert es nicht so gut, weil sagen jetzt schon zwei Leute sagen, naja, also es funktioniert für mich nicht so richtig gut, es funktioniert auch im Umfeld nicht so richtig gut. Deswegen würden wir uns dann, glaube ich, jetzt mal der Politik wenden. Fabian, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank für den Einblick in deine Filter-Bubblen. Und mal gucken, was draus wird.
Da war ja nur eine. Ich hätte ja noch zwei. Aber gut, okay, ich lasse dich in deinem Programm weiter machen.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen deprimierend auch. Ist es für euch eigentlich noch deprimierend, das zu hören, dass Leute anrufen und sagen, zwei Jahre danach gibt es immer noch viele Menschen, denen das eigentlich Latte ist, weil Griechenland ist viel gefährlicher?
Das gibt es ja bei jedem Thema. Ich kenne auch Menschen, denen Griechenland Latte ist. Und ich kenne eine ganze Menge Menschen, denen das Schicksal der Hühner, die sie essen, Latte ist. Das ist, glaube ich, bei jedem politischen Thema genauso. Es gibt immer einen Teil Menschen, die sich für das Thema interessieren, die darin eine Gefahr sehen und eine Menge Verbesserungspotenzial, das sie gerne erreichen möchten. Und das Ziel ist einfach nur, dieses Verbesserungspotenzial zu erreichen, damit alle davon profitieren. Und das, worauf, denke ich, wir alle drei, aber Andre und Anne, insbesondere, hinarbeiten, ist ja das genau, da eine Verbesserung eintritt, von der am Ende alle profitieren und da wird dann auch nicht differenziert werden nach der Revolution. Wer das jetzt vorher wollte oder nicht, das machen wir für alle.
Okay, so, dann kommen wir jetzt zu dem Thema, was schon ganz oft angesprochen wurde und was wir jetzt mal näher beleuchten wollen.
Revolutionstheorien.
Nein, den NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Herrgott nochmal, wir brauchen mehr Sendezeit. Flo Heiler, der nach uns senden wird, der braucht heute glaube ich, der muss keine Musik spielen. Nein, im Ernst, NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Also es gibt politische Außerarbeitung. Ich wollte vorher eigentlich, vielleicht können wir es noch ganz kurz beleuchten, bevor wir dazu kommen. Die Politik sagt ja immer so, also Politik ungeheim, die sagen ja so generell so, also tendenziell, ne, wir machen da, also die anderen sind die Bösen, wir machen eigentlich alles richtig, also hier in Deutschland und dann kommt so Schritt für Schritt raus. Das ist ja doch gar nicht so. Hängt das alles mit dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss auch zusammen oder ist da auch noch über andere Ecken was rausgekommen?
Ich habe die Frage nicht verstanden.
Na also die Politik, wenn ich die Politik in Deutschland beobachte, ist es so, die sagen erst mal so, ne, wir wissen von nichts und wir machen auch nichts Ungesetzliches. Und dann kommt Schritt für Schritt raus, naja, das stimmt nicht ganz, das stimmt eigentlich ganz schön doll nicht, das stimmt eigentlich überhaupt nicht. Ist das das Ergebnis, was der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss bringt oder gibt es da noch andere Wege, durch die das forciert wurde?
Na, also ich glaube, dieses Mantra der Bundesregierung, alles ist voll rechtmäßig und alles ist genau richtig und wir halten uns an alle Gesetze und die Amerikaner auch und überhaupt alle. Das ist sozusagen das Mantra, was erstmal vorgetragen wird, um zu hoffen, dass damit möglichst viele Leute das glauben und einfach nicht weiter nachfragen und denken, das hat schon alles seine Richtigkeit, die machen das schon. Und das dann nebenbei jetzt doch eine ganze Menge rausgekommen ist, wo doch sehr deutlich geworden ist, das haut nicht hin, irgendwer hält sich nicht an Gesetze. Und dahinter dann noch die Frage, ist das schon alles, was wir wollen, dass sich an diese Gesetze gehalten wird? Oder ist auch bei den Gesetzen vielleicht noch so ein bisschen der Wurm drin? Weil die ganz schön viel Überwachung auch ermöglichen und viel unkontrollierten Geheimdienst, der alles Mögliche macht, aber nichts darüber verrät, was das ist. Selbst wenn das jetzt also voll rechtmäßig wäre und die sich an alles hielten, ist das immer noch nicht das, was ich will. Und das ist jetzt aber natürlich nicht nur der Untersuchungsausschuss, der das herausgefunden hat, sondern doch auch eine ganze Menge anderer. Eben angefangen mit Snowden, der das Thema aufgebracht hat. Ganz viele Leute, die nachfragen, ganz viele Leute, die darüber berichten. Und auch andere Gremien, also auch allein die parlamentarische Aufarbeitung findet ja nicht nur im Untersuchungsausschuss statt, sondern über Fragen an die Bundesregierung der Abgeordneten, über die anderen Ausschüsse auch, Innenausschuss und so weiter. Dann gibt es noch die anderen Kontrollgremien, wobei bei denen eben der Haken ist, dass sie völlig nicht öffentlich sind und kein Mensch weiß, was da stattfindet und auch nie erfahren wird. Aber die alle bohren natürlich jetzt gerade darum.
Aber das bekannteste Instrument, wenn man jetzt öffentliche Berichterstattung verfolgt, ist schon dieser NS-Untersuchungsausschuss. Und jetzt könnt ihr bitte mal erzählen, was passiert da eigentlich genau eigentlich, wozu ist der gut, was macht ihr da und überhaupt?
Es war einmal.
Also wie ist es überhaupt dazu gekommen?
Na Snowden, ne? Juni 2013 war Snowden und dann hatten wir Wahlkampf. Und dann hat Pofalla die Affäre für beendet erklärt. Und andere haben erklärt, dass unter Freunden nicht spioniert wird. Und dann gab es eine Wahl, die für die Koalition ganz gut gelaufen ist, weil wir jetzt eine 80-prozentige Mehrheit der großen Koalition von SPD und CDU haben. Und ich glaube, wenn diese Wahl nicht zwei Monate nach Snowden gewesen wäre, wäre es vielleicht nicht unbedingt zu so einem Untersuchungsausschuss gekommen. Weiß ich nicht, vielleicht täusche ich mich da auch. Aber ich denke, dass das damit dazu zu tun hatte, dass es eben einstimmig, also durch alle Fraktionen, die Entscheidung gab, dass so ein Untersuchungsausschuss eingerichtet werden soll. Die ganze Debatte darüber hat, nachdem sich das Parlament so ein bisschen sortiert hat, der erstmal auch eine ganze Weile gedauert. Und dann im März 2014 hat das Parlament mit allen Stimmen aller Fraktionen eben beschlossen, es gibt einen Untersuchungsausschuss. Und der hat dann vor jetzt einem guten Jahr seine Arbeit angefangen.
Jetzt, der heißt ja NSL-Untersuchungsausschuss. Man hört aber immer Ergebnisse...
Nee, heißt der nicht. Der heißt Erster Parlamentarischer Untersuchungsausschuss. Erster PUA. Fertig aus.
Legislaturperiode.
Genau, der wird genannt, NSL-Untersuchungsausschuss. Also NSL kommt da sozusagen... Ich meine, es geht ja nicht nur um die NSA. Es geht um die Five Eyes, also um diesen Geheimdienstverbund aus fünf Staaten. Und inzwischen, finde ich, müsste man den eher BND-Untersuchungsausschuss nennen oder Massenüberwachungsuntersuchungsausschuss oder...
Okay, danke, dass du die Frage beantwortest. Was ist denn eigentlich der Auftrag?
Der Auftrag sind acht Seiten. Hör ich ja dabei. Ich hab einen Zettel, wo ich sämtliche Punkte, weil ich das selber auch immer nicht alles flüssig hin gehe. Es gibt drei Teile in diesem Untersuchungsauftrag. Der erste ist im Grunde, dass das untersucht werden soll, was diese Überwachung durch die Five Eyes starten. Also USA, Großbritannien sind die bekanntesten, Kanada, Australien, Neuseeland gehören auch noch mit dazu. Das ist dieser sehr eng zusammen arbeitende Geheimdienstverbund. Also diese Überwachung durch die Five Eyes untersuchen soll. Und da drin gibt es dann eine ganze Reihe von Unterpunkten. Die interessantesten dabei sind auch die Beteiligung am Geheimen Krieg, also dem Drohnenkrieg, der in Deutschland über die US-Basis in Rammstein geführt wird, inwieweit der BND oder die deutsche Regierung daran mit beteiligt sind. Ein anderer, finde ich, ziemlich relevanter Unterpunkt ist die Rolle der Flüchtlingsbefragungen, an denen auch Vertreter der Five Eyes beteiligt sind, mit ganz klassischem Aufklärungsinteresse aus diesen Flüchtlingsbefragungen. Wenn Leute aus Regionen hierher kommen, die Zielregionen der NSA sind, dann haben die halt bestimmte Fragen an diese Flüchtlinge. Das soll auch mit aufgeklärt werden. Und ansonsten geht es aber eben ganz viel um Erkenntnisse über Überwachung gegen Unternehmen und wie sich davor technisch geschützt wurde und was die Bundesregierung darüber bisher wusste und was sie dagegen tut und zu tun gedenkt und so weiter. Also da gibt es eine ganze Reihe von Unterpunkten, die sich alle mit dieser Überwachung durch die Five Eyes beschäftigen. Der zweite Punkt des Auftrages ist konkret die Überwachung der Bundesregierung selbst, des Bundes als solchen und seiner Institutionen, der Parlamentarier und der Verfassungsorgane ganz gezielt durch die Five Eyes. Und der dritte Teil des Untersuchungsauftrages sind dann Empfehlungen zur Wahrung der informationellen Selbstbestimmung und der Privatsphäre. Das heißt, da soll es einen Empfehlungsteil geben, das würde der CCC jetzt nicht machen, aber jedenfalls das Untersuchungsausschuss hat als Aufgabe, Empfehlungen für die Bundesregierung und für den Bundestag zu entwickeln, zu sagen, folgende Fehler haben wir gefunden und das sollte passieren, damit das nicht mehr vorkommt.
Andre, du beobachtest dieses Ding ja für nestpolitik.org. Also du sitzt immer bei den öffentlichen Sitzungen da und bloggst live und machst hinterher sozusagen eine Riesenzusammenfassung. Was genau passiert in diesem Ausschuss oder was ist passiert bis jetzt?
Tja, vielleicht mal kurz zu meiner Rolle, weil du es ansprichst. Also es gibt manche Sitzungen mit Zeugen und Sachverständigen, die tagen öffentlich. Da kann jeder hingehen. Also nicht nur Journalisten. Da kann sich jeder auf der Webseite des Bundestages und des Untersuchungsausschusses einfach anmelden. Eine E-Mail reicht. Also wenn die öffentlich tagen, kann da auch wirklich jeder hin. Das kann ich auch nur empfehlen. Das Problem ist, dass es davon keine offiziellen Mitschnitte gibt. Nichts veröffentlicht wird, kein Video oder Audio oder so. Und dass man quasi nur das mitnehmen kann, was man mitschreiben kann. Also versuchen wir, möglichst alles mitzuschreiben und möglichst live ins Internet zu stellen, weil wir haben da genug Platz. Und das macht Spaß, ist interessant. Wird aber auch ganz gut nachgefragt. Und da jetzt die Frage, was der Ausschuss in einem Jahr Arbeit herausbekommen hat, beim Blick auf die Sendezeit, sollten wir vielleicht bei den allerwichtigsten Punkten bleiben. Also es ging tatsächlich schon mal los mit einem ziemlichen Paukenschlag. Bei der allerersten öffentlichen Sitzung kamen die drei Granden der deutschen Verfassungsrechtler und haben alle unisono erklärt, also die gesamte Auslandsaufklärung des BND ist eigentlich komplett rechtswidrig. Da haben dann auch die Vertreter der großen Koalition ein bisschen gestaunt, weil die haben ja zwei von denen eingeladen und die Opposition zusammen nur eine, weil so sind nun mal die Mehrheitsverhältnisse in diesem Parlament, 80 zu 20. Dementsprechend sind dann auch die Zeitbudgets und die Zeugen und Sachverständigen von der Opposition nur ziemlich dürftig. Trotzdem haben die alle gesagt, dass es komplett illegal, wie der BND im Ausland agiert. Zumindest gibt es keine rechtliche Basis. Das war schon mal ein krasser Auftakt. Und dann kamen nach und nach Zeugen von Telekom, Dezix, aber vor allem auch eben BND, die erklären mussten, mal mehr, mal weniger enthusiastisch, wie denn das nun vonstattengeht, wie der BND involviert ist in die Massenüberwachung, welche Kabel angezapft werden, welche Satellitenstrecken angezapft werden und welche Informationen dadurch an andere Dienste, meistens die USA im Sinne von NSA und CIA, gegeben werden. Und dann das neueste große Thema ist das mit den sogenannten Selektoren, was jetzt in den letzten Wochen hochgeploppt ist. Aber da ist dann viel Detailarbeit für den Ausschuss. Die haben irgendwie hunderttausende Aktenordner, soweit ich das höre, wo man sich durchkämpfen muss, was halt irgendwie als Opposition mit drei, vier Leuten nicht so wirklich gut zu machen ist. Und dann gibt es teilweise Zeugen da drin von BND, die eine Frage kriegen und dann gucken sie nach links zur Bundesregierung, kriegen den Signal und sagen dann ins Mikrofon, habe ich vergessen. Solche Dinge passieren in dem Ausschuss. Es ist dann nicht immer ganz einfach, den Überblick zu behalten in den Details. Aber immerhin haben wir mit der Feststellung, dass der BND rechtswidrig im Ausland agiert. Und durch so Operationen wie Iconal und Gloteig, zu denen wir schon ein bisschen was gehört haben, also Glasfaserabschmuschel-Aktionen, jetzt mal herausbekommen, wie der BND arbeitet. Und das ist schon mal ein guter Schritt auf den Weg zur Aufklärung, wie wir dann in dem nächsten Schritt eben damit umgeben, was daraus folgt, welche politischen Konsequenzen gezogen werden.
Gibt es eigentlich eine Begründung dafür, dass dieser Ausschuss öffentlich ist, aber irgendwie nicht offiziell dokumentiert wird? Also die anderen öffentlichen Geschehnisse, die ich so an den Bundestag verfolge oder mal teilgenommen habe, die wurden eigentlich durchaus dann auch dokumentiert öffentlich gemacht.
Ja, das ist so eine rechtliche Verdrehung. Die Zeugen, die da geladen werden, die werden so ähnlich wie in einem Gerichtsverfahren vernommen. Und die offizielle Ansage ist, dass sich kommende Zeugen nicht über die Aussagen der vorherigen Zeugen informieren sollen, damit die unbefangen, unabgesprochen, unabhängig voneinander aussagen. Das ist auch der Grund, warum die offiziellen Protokolle leider nicht veröffentlicht werden. Nur sagen alle BND-Zeugen offen im Ausschuss, die lesen halt unsere Protokolle auf Netzpolitikruck. Diese Ausrede hat sich dann auch gegessen. Aber irgendwann werden auch die Protokolle der Zeugenvernehmungen der öffentlichen Teile veröffentlicht, und zwar spätestens mit dem Abschlussbericht dieses Untersuchungsausschusses.
Jetzt ist Andre da als sozusagen öffentlicher Beobachter. Du bist Fachreferentin für die Fraktion Die Linke. Was genau ist da deine Aufgabe?
Ja, einfach alles, was mit dem Ausschuss zu tun hat, irgendwie im Auge zu behalten, zu koordinieren, die Akten zu lesen, die Abgeordneten mit den notwendigen Informationen zu versorgen, auch Fragenkataloge für die Ausschusssitzungen zu schreiben, auch so ganz banalen Kram wie, es gibt geheime Akten, die müssen aus der Geheimschutzstelle abgeholt und ins Büro getragen werden. Ich bin die einzige Referentin, dann gibt es aber noch ein paar Mitarbeiter, zwei, die solche Sachen machen dürfen, einfach einen Überblick behalten. Dann gibt es Referententreffen von den Referenten der verschiedenen Fraktionen, die im Grunde vorbesprechen, was die Abgeordneten dann im Ausschuss machen. Es gibt ja einerseits die öffentlichen Anhörungen, die bei Netzpolitik beschrieben werden, über die berichtet wird auch viel in der Presse. Und daneben gibt es aber natürlich auch noch nicht öffentliche Sitzungen und Obleutesitzungen, wo entschieden wird beispielsweise, welche Zeugen eigentlich geladen werden, welche Themen eigentlich aufgerufen werden, wo bestimmte Fragen gestellt werden, wo ganz viele Auseinandersetzungen mit der Bundesregierung auch stattfinden, darüber, dass die Akten, ganz viel in den Akten geschwärzt ist, dass es da eine ganze Reihe von Verfahrensproblemen gibt, wo die Bundesregierung die Arbeit des Ausschusses behindert und wo die Abgeordneten sich darüber beschweren. Diese ganzen Auseinandersetzungen darüber, ob Snowden als Zeuge in den Ausschuss geladen wird, was ja dann in der Verfassungsklage der Opposition gipfelte, hat auch in diesen nicht öffentlichen Sitzungen stattgefunden. Und das wird dann eben von Referenten vorbereitet. Und das ist auch mit meinem Job.
Das ist auch mal interessant zu wissen. Also da sitzen dann gar keine MdBs, also Bundestagsabgeordneten mit drin, sondern die erfahren alles, was in diesem Ausschuss passiert, noch mal durch eine Filter-Ebene, nämlich genau die Referenten, die für die Abgeordneten oder für die Fraktionen dann da sitzen.
Na, es gibt beides. Es gibt sozusagen diese Referententreffen. Und dann gibt es die Obleutetreffen, wo sozusagen für jede Fraktion gibt es einen Obmann oder eine Obfrau, sozusagen Sprecher der Fraktion im Ausschuss. Und diese vier vorbesprechen bestimmte Sachen, die vorher von den Referenten vorbesprochen wurden, was einfach damit zu tun hat, dass MdBs... Also ich finde, das hat durchaus Sinn. Dafür gibt es ja Mitarbeiter im Parlament, weil MdBs einfach hier auch nicht nur diesen einen Ausschuss haben, sondern gerade in den kleinen Fraktionen noch eine ganze Reihe von anderen Ausschüssen und Funktionen. Und eine Dichte von Themen an einem Tag zu verarbeiten haben, was mich persönlich ziemlich stressen würde, muss ich sagen, obwohl ich das auch so schon ganz ordentlich intensiv finde. Insofern ist das schon sinnvoll, dass es Leute gibt, die das sozusagen so ein bisschen vorkauen, sage ich mal. Und das natürlich aber auch vorher mit den MdBs jeweils innerhalb der Fraktionen besprechen. Und genau, das wird dann eben in diesen nichtöffentlichen Sitzungen letztlich beschlossen. Und daraus entstehen dann die Tagesordnung und öffentliche Anhörungen.
Es sind jetzt dieses Werkzeug unserer Demokratie. Wenn man so Meinung darüber hat, dann schwankt das zwischen diesen beiden Extremen. Das ist genau super, das ist genau das, was wir brauchen. Und der zahnlose Papiermonster bringt eigentlich nichts. Da reden halt Leute vieler Namen. Wie ist eure Meinung dazu? Ist das jetzt das richtige Werkzeug? Bringt das die Ergebnisse, die ihr euch gewünscht habt? Also vielleicht nicht die Ergebnisse, die ihr euch inhaltlich gewünscht habt, aber sozusagen zumindest wird das bearbeitet, was ihr euch gewünscht habt?
Also ich finde es schon cool, dass es diesen Ausschuss gibt, sonst hätte ich auch diesen Job nicht machen wollen. Das ist ja nicht erzwungen über mich gekommen, sondern ich wollte das gerne machen, weil ich das als Thema total spannend fand, die Möglichkeit überhaupt parlamentarisch aufzuarbeiten und über ein schon relativ gut ausgerüstetes parlamentarisches Instrument untersuchen zu können, was die Regierung und was der Geheimdienst da macht und wie das alles mit der Massenüberwachung der NSA und den Enthüllungen von Snowden zusammenhängt. Das ist eine ziemlich einmalige Gelegenheit, finde ich. Und deswegen fand ich das und finde ich das sehr spannend. Nicht nur, weil ich Einblick in irgendwelche geheimen Dokumente habe, sondern wegen der Sachen, die dabei rauskommen. Und gleichzeitig ist es so, dass eben wegen der Mehrheitsverhältnisse, so wie sie sind, in diesem Ausschuss sind acht Abgeordnete plus Stellvertreter. Davon sind vier von der Union, zwei von der SPD, eine von den Linken und einer von den Grünen. Und es wird in der Regel nach Mehrheit entschieden, wenn nicht gemeinsam entschieden wird. Es gibt häufig Einigungsprozesse, deswegen sind diese Vorbesprechungen auch wichtig, wo gesagt wird, wir gemeinsam wollen bestimmte Zeugen vernehmen. Was die Motive sind, warum wir das wollen versus warum die Union das will, die sind vielleicht noch mal unterschiedlich an bestimmten Punkten, die sich vielleicht auch keine Blöße geben, weil sie natürlich auch als Abgeordnete der Union in diesem Ausschuss sind, erst mal nach außen hin mit dem Auftrag, das aufzuklären, der gewesenen Oppmann Kiesewetter hat immer sehr deutlich gesagt, dass sein Interesse ist, mit dem Ausschuss zu belegen, dass alles in Ordnung ist. Klar ist das ein unterschiedliches Motiv und klar sind wir uns denn nicht unbedingt einig, immer einig gewesen, was das Vorgehen angeht, aber zumindest ist das pro forma erstmal so. Und jetzt habe ich einen Faden verloren.
Also es geht um die Endkündigung, ob das sozusagen ein scharfes Werkzeug ist. Ich nehme dein Wort und so, es könnte besser sein, aber für die Situation, in der wir uns befinden, ist es schon auch gut genug.
Ich finde, es ist zumindest erstmal, ist das ein Instrument, was wir haben und das sollten wir nutzen, deswegen tun wir das. Und ich finde übrigens, dass es schon jetzt nach einem Jahr sehr viel mehr rausgekommen ist, als ich eigentlich erwartet hatte, weil ich eben genau wegen dieser Mehrheitsverhältnisse, deswegen bin ich jetzt darauf gekommen, damit gerechnet habe, dass wir eigentlich gar nichts rauskriegen. Der Ausschuss ist davon abhängig, dass die Bundesregierung bestimmte Dokumente aushändigt. Und auch wenn sie rechtlich dazu verpflichtet sind, alle Dokumente auszuhändigen, nach denen, die der Ausschuss haben will, weil Parlament kontrolliert Regierung, deswegen kann Parlament sagen, Regierung, gib mal her. Ist das natürlich nicht kontrollierbar und ob das dann alles ist, ist immer zweifelhaft. Es hat auch schon Fälle gegeben, mehrfach jetzt im Ausschuss, wo wir im Nachhinein festgestellt haben, da haben sie was vergessen, da haben sie was übersehen, da sind ein paar Ordner untergegangen und dann hat aus Versehen ein Zeuge drüber geredet und dann konnten sie nicht mehr verheimlichen, dass es die gibt und mussten diese zusätzlichen Dokumente dann auch... Also das gibt es. Dazu gibt es die Mehrheitsverhältnisse. Das heißt, wenn es Sachen gibt, die der Regierung zu deutlich gegen den Strich gehen, dann steht natürlich die Koalition bei Fuß und sagt, gibt es nicht. Da ist jetzt diese Selektoren-Geschichte ein ganz typisches Beispiel. Die SPD pöbelt ganz laut rum und im Ausschuss stimmen sie aber immer mit der Union gegen die Anträge der Opposition und verhindern damit eine Einsicht in diese Selektorenlisten oder überhaupt eine Lösung, wie durch den Ausschuss eingesehen werden kann, worum es bei diesen Selektorenlisten gibt. Diese Mehrheitsverhältnisse sind so und damit haben wir eigentlich eine relativ schwierige Situation für die Aufklärung. Denn die Koalitionsparteien, also Fraktionen, SPD und Union, schützen natürlich ihre Regierung. Die Parlamentarier haben durchaus teilweise, würde ich sagen, schon in ihrer Parlamentarier-Ähre und die ist in der Regel bei MDB sehr ausgeprägt, natürlich in dieser Rolle auch ein bisschen ein Interesse, was aufzuklären. Aber wenn es um irgendwas Interessantes geht, dann schützen sie die Regierung. Damit haben wir als Opposition relativ wenig Chance.
Also Verfahrensfehler werden wahrscheinlich aufgeklärt, aber die Revolution würde nicht stattfinden.
Genau, ich glaube, die Revolution kann ein parlamentarischer Ausschuss sowieso nicht anleuten. Das widerspricht sich vollständig. Sowas kann ein Ausschuss nicht machen. Das muss die Öffentlichkeit, das muss die Bevölkerung machen, wenn sie es denn haben will. Also nur grundsätzlich verändern muss sie auch ihren Willen deutlich machen, nicht nur über die Wahl, sondern z.B. Demonstrationen und deutlichere Willensbekundungen. Aber der Ausschuss kann ziemlich viel aufklären. Und da ist echt erstaunlich viel schon zutage gekommen.
Okay, dann will ich gleich nochmal genauer wissen, was für dich diese Ergebnisse sind, wo du sagst, okay, das ist schon erstaunlich, dass du das rausgefunden hast. Wir machen erst nochmal eine letzte kleine Pause mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Dann geht es hier nochmal eine halbe Stunde weiter im Chaosradio im Blue Moon.
Das Line-up ist komplett. Und verrückte Welt. Die neuen Deutschpoeten sind gar nicht neun, sondern sogar zehn.
Die neuen Deutschpoeten.
Yandilay. Bilderbuch.
Und Anne-Malcantereit.
Tonbandgerät. Die neuen Deutschpoeten.
Freitag, Vierter und Samstag, Fünfter, September. Live im IFRA Sommergarten der Messe Berlin.
Solang's noch Karten gibt.
Gibt's Karten im Kombi-Ticket für beide Tage. Oder einzeln für Freitag oder Samstag. fritz.de slash deutschpoeten.
Die neuen Deutschpoeten.
Das fritz Open Air Festival.
Immer gute neue Musik. Fritz Nachrichten.
FIFA-Präsident Blatter hat zum ersten Mal etwas zum Korruptionsskandal gesagt. Zu Beginn des FIFA-Kongresses in Zürich sagte er, dass er sich nichts vorzuwerfen hat. Den Korruptionsskandal bezeichnet er als eine Schande für den Fußball. Der Europäische Fußballverband UEFA hatte Blatter heute aufgefordert, zurückzutreten. Morgen stellt sich Blatter beim FIFA-Kongress für eine fünfte Amtszeit zur Wahl. Die UEFA dann gekündigt, ihn nicht zu wählen. Verfassungsschützer fordern, dass junge Leute besser über Propaganda von Extremisten aufgeklärt werden. Rechtsextremisten und Terrorgruppen wie der Islamische Staat nutzen immer stärker YouTube und Facebook, um Jugendliche anzuwerben. Über dieses Problem wurde heute bei einer Tagung der ostdeutschen Verfassungsschutzbehörden in Potsdam gesprochen. Experten warnen davor, dass Extremisten über das Internet in Sekunden schnelle Jugendliche überall auf der Welt erreichen und beeinflussen können. Waffen an Bord eines Flugzeugs zu schmuggeln, ist in Deutschland wie es aussieht einfacher als in anderen europäischen Ländern. Das sagt die EU-Kommission. Sie hatte im Dezember verdeckte Prüfer zum Frankfurter Flughafen geschickt. Bei jedem zweiten Versuch gelang es ihnen Waffen oder andere verbotene Gegenstände mit an Bord zu nehmen. Weil bisher nichts dagegen die mangelhaften Passagierkontrollen getan wurde, verklagt die EU-Kommission Deutschland jetzt vor dem Europäischen Gerichtshof. In der Fußball-Bundesliga war am Abend die Hinrunde der Relegation. Das Spiel Hamburg gegen Karlsruhe ist 1 zu 1 ausgegangen. Die Entscheidung darüber, ob der Hamburger Verein zum ersten Mal in seiner Geschichte in die zweite Liga absteigt und Karlsruhe aufsteigt, fällt jetzt beim Rückspiel, das ist am Montag. Alba Berlin hat im Halbfinalduell der Basketball-Bundesliga gegen Bayern München verloren, 73 zu 85 ist es ausgegangen, damit steht es in der Best of 5 Serie 1 zu 1. Das Wetter Wir haben in Berlin-Rheinikendorf 11 und in Treptow 12 Grad, Falkensee und Bad Freienwalde 10, Bielezeitstätten 11, Cottbus 13 Grad. In der Nacht kann es immer mal wieder regnen, bei Temperaturen zwischen 10 und 4 Grad minimal. Morgen wird es dann wechselhaft, es gibt Sonne, Wolken und Regen bei 18 bis höchstens 22 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin 100, Stadtring Richtung Wedding zwischen Kurfürstendamm und Dreieck Funkturm sind zwei Spuren gesperrt. 111 Stadtautobahn Stadtauswärts im Tunnelflughafen Tegel ist nach einem Unfall die linke Spur gesperrt. Tiergartenstraße des 17. Juni zwischen Brandenburger Tor und Jetzerkrabinstraße gibt es eine Vollsperrung bis zum 11. Ebenfalls komplett gesperrt ist die Ebertstraße am Brandenburger Tor. Grund ist das UEFA Champions League Festival. Und noch was zur S-Bahn. Auf der S8 fahren bis Betriebsschluss Busse statt Bahnen, und zwar zwischen Blankenburg und Hohen-Neuen-Dorf. Woche mal seit. Gute Fahrt!
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby. Und wenn ihr diesen Sound mögt......oder diesen Sound......dann hört doch mal den Fritz Soundgarden mit Maurice Geider. Immer sonntags ab 20 Uhr und im Radio.
Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de.
Tschüss Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon, das heißt einer der Blue Moone, wo Leute aus dem Chaos Computer Club oder dem Umfeld zu Gast sind und über Themen reden, die mit dem Internet zu tun haben. Heute geht es um zwei Jahre Snowden, was davon umgeblieben ist, was wir davon lernen konnten. Zu Gast sind Linus Neumann, Andre Meister und Anne Roth. Hallo und guten Abend noch mal, zum letzten Mal. Und zwei davon haben näher mit dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss im Bundestag zu tun. Andre Meister geht da als ganz normaler Bürger hin und bloggt dann reichhaltig drüber. Anne Roth ist da als Fachreferentin für die Linke, Teil dieses Ausschusses. Und Anne, du hast gerade erzählt, so ein bisschen von der Arbeit da, aber auch, dass du das als Werkzeug sozusagen nicht ganz das ist, was man sich vielleicht wünscht, aber doch ein paar erstaunliche Ergebnisse zutage gebracht haben. Was sind denn das für diese Ergebnisse, wo du sagst, okay, das ist ganz cool, dass wir das herausgefunden haben?
Na, es gibt eine ganze Menge so, ich schreibe mich so ein bisschen das Kleinkram zu nennen, aber letztlich, so wenn man das große Ganze betrachtet, sind das kleinere Erkenntnisse, die vorher zumindest nicht so richtig nachweisbar waren, was es an Rechtsbrüchen durch den BND gibt. Also eins davon zum Beispiel macht die Runde als Weltraumtheorie. Das ist rausgekommen, als der BND hat eine eigene Datenschützerin und als Frau Dr. F die Datenschützerin des BND, vor dem Ausschuss erklärt hat, dass sie einen Dissens hat mit dem Präsidenten des BND, weil sie festgestellt hat, als eben Datenschutzbeauftragte, dass alle Daten, die der BND an Satelliten erfasst, vom BND nicht als dem BND-Gesetz unterfallend betrachtet werden, was aus ihrer Perspektive deswegen eine Rolle spielt, weil dann Datenschutzregelungen für diese Daten angewandt werden müssten. Und Schindler und der BND-Präsident sind aber der Meinung, Schindler ist der Präsident des Bundesnachrichtendienstes, mit dem sie das, so hat sie das beschrieben, auch versucht hat auszudiskutieren, aber er ist halt der Chef und hat sich damit durchgesetzt, ist der Meinung, das sind Daten, das sind Daten, die nicht auf deutschem Boden erfasst werden, sondern eben im Weltraum und deswegen gilt das BND-Gesetz nicht und deswegen müssen wenigstens diese Datenschutzregelungen auf diese Daten nicht angewandt werden. Das klingt jetzt ziemlich juristisch und so ziemlich spitzfindig, aber hat natürlich durchaus Auswirkungen. Sie hat auch erzählt beispielsweise, dass eine Reihe von Datenbanken durch den BND-Datensammlungen geführt werden, von denen es keine Dateianordnungen gibt, was auch aus Datenschutzperspektiven ein Problem ist. Das heißt, es ist nicht dokumentiert, was sind das für Daten in diesen Datenbanken, warum und wofür werden die geführt. Das ist eigentlich eine Vorschrift, die im Datenschutz auf jeden Fall immer für alle Dateien gilt. Dann gibt es noch so eine Theorie, das ist die Funktionsträger-Theorie, die ein anderer Zeuge dem Ausschuss offenbart hat. Und die bedeutet, dass Deutsche, und da sind wir ein bisschen bei der Frage von vorhin, gilt das jetzt wie so beschäftigt ihr euch nur mit deutschen Staatsbürgern und die Amerikaner nur mit Amerikanern, so sind halt die Gesetze hier im Moment. Und die schützen vor allen Dingen durch den Artikel 10 des Grundgesetzes, eben die Telekommunikation vor Überwachung von Deutschen. Und wiederum, das, was Andre vorhin gesagt hat, das ist, was die drei Verfassungsrichter muniert haben und gesagt haben, G10 ist kein deutsches Grundrecht, sondern ein Grundrecht, das gilt für alle Menschen, aber das wird von der Bundesregierung anders gesehen. Und es ist ihnen auch völlig egal, dass selbst das CSU-Mitglied Papier, ehemaliger Bundesverfassungsgerichtspräsident, der Meinung ist, dass man das so nicht machen kann. Dann ist also der Bundesregierung egal. Deswegen gilt das nur für Deutsche in der aktuellen Auslegung der Bundesregierung und damit auch das BND. Und das wird insofern auch noch ausgehebelt, dass Deutsche beispielsweise, die sich im Ausland befinden und dort für zum Beispiel nicht deutsche Firmen arbeiten oder als Journalisten für CNN oder so, nicht als deutsche Staatsbürger durch das G10-Grundrecht geschützt sind, sondern als Funktionsträger gesehen werden. Und damit zumindest, weil es ihre nicht-private Kommunikation, also ihre berufliche Kommunikation, die nicht geschützt werden, obwohl sie Deutsche sind, gibt es auch eine ganze Menge von Juristen, die sagen, das ist völlig absurd, diese Interpretation, aber der BND finde das voll okay. Und so von dieser Kategorie von Sachen, da könnte ich jetzt noch reihenweise aufziehen. Ich sehe schon, Zeit haben wir nicht, aber da gibt es echt noch eine Menge von Sachen, die bisher einfach nicht so richtig deutlich belegt waren. Ich finde das einerseits wichtig, dass das rauskommt. Auf der anderen Seite habe ich so ein bisschen Sorge. Die SPD hat damit jetzt schon angefangen, ein Gesetz zu erarbeiten, wo die Weltraumtheorie aufgeräumt werden soll, dass sozusagen diese illegalen Praktiken des BND jetzt einfach im Nachhinein durch Gesetze legitimiert werden. Das ist natürlich überhaupt nicht das, was mein Ziel und unser Ziel mit dem Untersuchungsausschuss ist. Da glaube ich ist auch wichtig, dass viel Öffentlichkeit dazu da ist und aufpasst, dass jetzt nicht einfach im Nachhinein so die Sicherheitsgesetze so ein bisschen angepasst werden. Nichtsdestotrotz finde ich aber gut, dass das überhaupt erst mal untersucht wird.
Okay, also es gibt Ergebnisse, die dann möglicherweise wiederum für zweifelhafte Dinge benutzt werden. Aber okay, immerhin, Andre, du als externer Beobachter, wie ist deine Einschätzung, was diesen Untersuchungsausschuss angeht? Ist das ein probates Mittel?
Ja, tatsächlich wird dort nicht die Revolution stattfinden. Das muss woanders geschehen. Immerhin haben wir jetzt in den Nachrichten gelernt, dass wir über das Internet den sekundenschnellen Jugendlichen überall auf der Welt erreichen und beeinflussen können. Das tun wir auch in Radiosendungen wie dieser. Trotzdem finde ich auch, dass der Ausschuss einige coole Sachen ans Licht gebracht hat. Auch wenn wahrscheinlich die ursprünglich von den Snowden-Enthüllungen sich abgeleitete Auftrag, tatsächlich was über die Five Eyes, über die Geheimnisse der USA und das GCHQ und so weiter zu erfahren, leider derzeit ziemlich dünn ist, weil im Gegensatz zu dem BND kann der Bundestag die nicht um Akten oder Zeugen zwingen, aber immerhin ist es gut, auch über den BND und die obskuren Rechtstheorien, die die da haben, ein bisschen was zu lernen über die Operationen, wie die operieren. Und wenn in der Bildzeitung in den US-Geheimdienstler sagt, dass die deutsche Regierung und der Ausschuss gefährlicher ist, als die Snowden-Enthüllungen, dann muss der schon irgendwas richtig machen. Andererseits sehe ich auch die Gefahr als Berufspessimist. Wir hatten in der Vergangenheit schon öfters mal Geheimdienst-Skandale in den 70ern, in den USA mit dem sogenannten Church-Committee. Und dann aber auch Anfang der Nuller 2001, der EU-Bericht zu dem globalen Überwachungssystem Echelon, wo genau das eigentlich schon alles drin stand. Da wurde schon mal an zwei Punkten der Geschichte vehement davor gewarnt, dass wir in ein alles Überwachungsnetz abgleiten könnten. Aber trotzdem ist nichts passiert. Im Gegenteil, es ist sogar noch schlimmer geworden. Und mit den derzeitigen Mehrheitsverhältnissen, also ich sehe das auch so kritisch wie Anna, wir müssen aufpassen, dass aus den Erkenntnissen, die wir jetzt aus Snowden und aus diesem Ausschuss ziehen, dass wir dann auch die richtigen Schlussfolgerungen ableiten und nicht, wie es eben aus der SPD zu hören ist, dass jetzt einfach legalisieren wollen, was vorher illegal war. Sondern wir sollten uns als Gesellschaft überlegen, was ist Überwachung? Wie wollen wir in einer freien demokratischen Gesellschaft miteinander umgehen? Wie hindert Überwachung Leute an der freien Entfaltung, an der freien Meinungsbildung, an freien Meinungsäußerung? Und was ist ein adäquates Mittel, damit umzugehen und dann Antworten da zu finden?
Jetzt ist ja die politische Aufarbeitung die eine Sache. Jetzt stelle ich mir gerade eine Frage, weil wir ja gerade auch gesagt haben, da sind auch Rechtsbrüche oder zumindest haben, gibt es Experten, die sagen, da finden Rechtsbrüche statt? Und da möchte ich eine Frage von Twitter weitergeben. Frufus fragt, könntest du mal fragen, warum die Regierung beziehungsweise der BND noch nicht in Grund und Boden geklagt wurden? Das ist ja tatsächlich jetzt, was man denkt, okay, wenn es Experten gibt, die sagen, das ist ein Rechtsbruch, dann könnte man noch vielleicht mal irgendwo klagen. Geht das überhaupt? Also kann man den BND verklagen? Und wenn ja, wird das gemacht?
Es wird gemacht. Es passiert in den USA, es passiert in Großbritannien und es passiert in Deutschland und jetzt auch in der ganzen EU. Also wir hatten schon vor den Snowden-Enthüllungen Leute, die in Deutschland gegen den BND geklagt haben, weil der BND in seiner jährlichen Statistik angegeben hat, 37 Millionen E-Mails im Jahr zu überwachen und dass Leuten ziemlich viel groß vorkam. Wie wir hören, ist das jetzt alles total untertrieben, diese offiziellen Zahlen. Aber da haben schon vorher Leute dagegen geklagt, gegen die anlasslose Massenüberwachung einmal alles aus bestimmten Kommunikationssträngen zu nehmen. Das hat jetzt neu an Fahrt aufgenommen. Immer mehr Leute denken darüber nachzuklagen. Der Dezix, der große Internetprovider in Frankfurt, hat angekündigt, gegen Überwachungsanordnungen zu klagen. Wir haben jetzt den Peter Pilz, einen grünen Politiker in Österreich, der in Österreich Strafanzeige gegen die Deutsche Telekom und den BND gestellt hat, weil er in Akten gefunden hat, dass der BND auf Anweisungen der NSA bestimmte Telekommunikationsleitungen von Österreich in den Rest der Welt abgeschnuschelt hat und nachdem er das in Österreich getan hat, gibt es jetzt auch entsprechende Strafanzeigen in Luxemburg, in der Schweiz und heute in den Niederlanden. Es wird immer mehr geklagt. Unsere Freunde von Privacy International in England hatten sogar schon erste Erfolge vor Gericht. Da hat ein Gericht gesagt, die Datenübermittlung der NSA an den britischen Geheimdienst war bis zu dem Urteil, also Dezember 2014, komplett illegal. Die dürfen das quasi nicht mehr verwenden. Dann wurde natürlich sofort nach dem Urteil das Gesetz geändert, damit das jetzt nicht mehr illegal ist. Trotzdem kann man denen da so ein paar Nadelstiche versetzen, auch wenn das natürlich nicht die Lösung ist. Denn wie wir sehen, interpretieren die sich ihre Gesetze nicht nur heimlich um, sondern sie scheißen komplett drauf. Deswegen ist das rechtliche Vorgehen nur ein Baustein in dem kompletten Arsenal, was wir haben.
So, dann müssen wir jetzt, also beinahe auch schon wieder zum Schluss kommen, deswegen die Frage, wie wird es denn jetzt weitergehen? Ich weiß, das ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig, in die Zukunft zu schauen, aber wir haben ja sozusagen so ein paar Dinge besprochen, die so ein bisschen funktionieren, wenigstens, und jetzt ist die Frage, was wird in Zukunft passieren? Also ein pessimistisches Bild, das ich aus dieser Sendung ableiten kann, ist, es wird politisch und gerichtlich so ein bisschen Aufklärung geben. Und das wird die Politik dazu benutzen, um Gesetze zu erlassen, die das, was jetzt an Massenbewachung schon stattfindet, einfach zu legalisieren. Und dann leben wir in ein, zwei, drei, fünf Jahren in einer schönen neuen Welt, wo wir alle sozusagen ganz legal überwacht werden. Das ist sozusagen das Worst-Case-Denarii, was ich jetzt ableiten könnte aus dem, was ihr mir heute erzählt habt.
Also ich mach mir, ich denke bei sowas immer an den Geschichtsunterricht an amerikanischen Highschools. Den habe ich auch mal genossen. Und irgendwann wird ja diese Snowden-Affäre zwangsläufig auch in diesem Geschichtsunterricht landen. Der fängt also, die amerikanische Geschichte ist nicht so lang, die fängt dann damit an, dass ihnen das Land von den Bewohnern geschenkt wurde und dann sind ganz viele Afrikaner gekommen, um ihnen zu helfen. So ungefähr wird da die Geschichte erzählt. Und ich frage mich, wie dieser Konflikt dann irgendwann mal in amerikanischen Geschichtsunterrichtsstunden behandelt wird. Und ich glaube, bisher wäre die Geschichte so, oder meine größte Sorge ist, dass man sagt so, als das den Menschen erzählt wurde, dass der Staat sie zu ihrer Sicherheit beschützt, war das ein Skandal. Da haben sie sich gegen gewehrt. Das wollten sie nicht. Sie konnten noch nicht verstehen, dass das alles notwendig ist, um uns vor den bösen Terroristen zu beschützen. Gleichzeitig glaube ich aber, dass die faktische Veränderung in der Gesellschaft, also was sich an neuen Produkten durchsetzt, was sich an neuen Bewusstsein durchsetzt, vielleicht sich gar nicht so sehr in den politischen Konsequenzen niederschlagen wird, die ich ebenso wichtig finde, die ich mir auch wünsche und die ich auch mit sehr großem Genuss gerade verfolge. Wenn also eine Kanzlerin, die im letzten Jahr noch einen von Abhörern unter Freunden, das geht gar nicht, erzählt hat, jetzt als Chefin der Überwacher enttarnt ist, die genau das mit anderen Ländern tun. Aber ich hoffe natürlich, dass diese Geschichte, dass dieser Vorfall in die Geschichte eingehen wird, als ein Paradigmenwechsel zu einer Gesellschaft, die wenigstens vorsichtiger geworden ist und die sich gewisser Risiken bewusst geworden ist und die hoffentlich sei es mit Gerichtsverfahren, sei es mit Selbstschutz, sei es mit anderen politischen Mitteln außer parlamentarischer Natur dafür gesorgt hat, dass dieser Massenüberwachung ein Einhalt geboten wird. Denn ich denke, was wir häufig außer Acht lassen, ist, wie unsere Gesellschaft sich nur in den vergangenen 20 Jahren in diese digitalisierte Form geschoben hat. Und dieser Prozess ist ja noch gar nicht zu Ende. Das heißt, wir werden alle immer mehr Aspekte unseres Lebens immer tiefer digitalisieren, immer mehr von Netzwerken durchdringen lassen. Und wir haben da große Potenziale für unsere Gesellschaft und fürchterliche Überwachungs- und Machtpotenziale. Denn das ist das, was am Ende mit dieser Überwachung einhergeht. Und nicht das Risiko des Einzelnen, sondern die Machtkonzentration auf wenige, die diese Gesellschaft manipulieren, leiten und kontrollieren können.
Was ich mir jetzt gerade frage, wenn man über diese Überwachungskanäle redet, dann gibt es ja immer so zwei Extreme in der Zukunft. Das eine ist so, wir landen in diesem voll überwachten, total schlimmen Staat. Das andere ist so, Geheimdienste werden abgeschafft. Niemand weiß mehr irgendwas über irgendjemanden, das der nicht völlig freiwillig hergibt. Ist auch vorstellbar, dass es so einen Mittelweg gibt, also dass man ab jetzt immer davon ausgehen kann, die Geheimdienste machen auf jeden Fall mehr, als ihnen erlaubt ist. Aber wir haben sowohl technisch als auch politisch die Möglichkeiten, sie zumindest so zu pisaken und zu ärgern, dass sie nicht ganz unkontrolliert sind. Und das ist sozusagen, dass wir weiterhin in so einem Mittelzustand durch die Gegend schweben, mit Überwachung, aber auch mit ein bisschen Wehrhaftigkeit.
Also ehrlich gestanden glaube ich nicht an den Mittelwegen, muss ich echt sagen. Wobei ich auch keine Utopie im Kopf habe, wo das denn hinführen soll, weil glaube ich momentan wirklich nur ganz wenige Leute sich trauen, tatsächlich realistisch zu finden und sich vorzustellen, eine Welt ohne Geheimdienste. Ich finde aber die Geheimdienste, wie wir sie haben und wie sie sich benehmen und immer schon benehmen und auch die Argumente, die jetzt gerade viel zu lesen sind, die da heißen, jetzt werde doch mal realistisch, hat immer schon Spione gegeben und die wird's immer geben und die halten sich nicht ein Gesetz, das ist nun mal so und irgendwie alle spionieren gegen alle und jetzt kommt auch mal auf den Boden, hier und reißt euch ein bisschen zusammen und nehmt das richtig hin. Ich weigere mich ein bisschen, das so zu sehen. Für mich glaube ich war so und da sind wir noch mal beim Thema der Sendung auch so ein wirklich Schlüsselmoment in Citizen 4, als Edward Snowden sagt, für ihn der Moment umzudenken und zu überlegen, Whistleblower zu werden, war als er realisiert hat, dass das Internet, mit dem er aufgewachsen ist, das Freiheit symbolisiert hat, Freiheit der Kommunikation ausprobieren zu können, freie Räume zu haben, Sachen selber gestalten zu können, dass das plötzlich total in Gefahr war und umkippt in einen totalen Überwachungsstaat, aber eine Totalüberwachung, die noch viel schlimmer ist, als das, was wir vorher hatten. Und das ist im Grunde auch das, was mich antreibt, wenn du nach dem Ausblick fragst, wenn ich mir denke, wir sind im Moment an einem Punkt in der Geschichte, wo alles, was an demokratischen Elementen mal entwickelt wurde, auch nach der deutschen Geschichte und so weiter, Grundgesetz etc. völlig zurückgedreht wird. Diese Überwachung, wie sie machen, Massenüberwachung, wie sie durch die Geheimdienste implementiert wird gerade, werden die Meinungsfreiheit und Pressefreiheit vollständig zerstören. Es wird nichts mehr davon übrig bleiben, wenn wir das so geschehen lassen. Und jetzt werde ich vielleicht so ein bisschen pathetisch, aber die Vorstellung, dass mich in irgendwann 20 Jahren meine Kinder oder Enkel mal fragen, wieso habt ihr denn nichts gemacht, als das stattgefunden hat? Wieso habt ihr euch nicht dagegen gewehrt? Wieso habt ihr euch das alles wegnehmen lassen? Motivieren mich dazu, zu versuchen, was geht, um das irgendwie aufzuhalten, weil ich das nicht akzeptieren kann.
Die werden sich doch niemals trauen, die Frage überhaupt zu stellen.
André, willst du auch nochmal in dieses Klagehorn stoßen?
Ja, ich wollte das echt nicht als Klage gesehen haben, sondern eher als Ding, irgendwie wir müssen jetzt was machen. Dass also einfach sich zurücklehnen und denken, wird schon, irgendwer regeln geht nicht.
Also ich bin ja Berufspessimist, aber tatsächlich möchte ich mich an den letzten Satz von Anna anschließen. Also wir befinden uns in einem gesellschaftlichen Aushandlungsprozess und wir haben jetzt ein Fenster der Möglichkeiten, wie es so schön heißt. Jetzt sind die Fakten auf dem Tisch. Jetzt ist der Skandal aktuell. Wir haben zwei Jahresnoden. Wir haben ein Jahr Untersuchungsausschuss. Wir erfahren immer mehr, wie Geheimdienste ja Gesetze aktiv brechen, die komplette Menschheit überwachen und demokratisch einfach von Definition her nicht zu kontrollieren sind. Also wir haben jetzt die Möglichkeit, uns dagegen zu wehren und eine demokratische Gesellschaft, wie wir uns vorstellen, stattdessen zu entfalten, die eben ohne die Schere im Kopf, das wird ja sowieso alles überwacht und kann gegen mich verwendet werden, funktionieren kann. Deswegen finde ich schon zwei Jahresnoden, ein Jahr Ausschuss. Wir sollten uns alle mehr einbringen. Man kann ruhig mal zu so einer Ausschusssitzung gehen. Oder man kann auch einfach mal zu einer Demo gegen Vorratsdatenspeicherung gehen. Jetzt kommt die Regierung auf die Idee ausgerechnet jetzt zum Thema unserer Sendung, irgendwie die anlasslose Massenüberwachung nicht nur von Geheimdiensten hinzunehmen, sondern jetzt auch für ganz normale Polizeibehörden, für stinknormale Drogendelikte auszuweiten, mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung einmal die komplette Menschheit in Deutschland zu überwachen und Bewegungsprofile von jedem zu erstellen. Und man kann sich so aus einbringen, ob es jetzt auch eine Demo gehen ist, mal zum Ausschuss gehen ist oder einfach mal den Abgeordneten der Wahl die Meinung sagen. Wir sind einen gesellschaftlichen Aushändlungsprozess. Wahrscheinlich werden wir in naher Zukunft nicht alle Geheimdienste abgeschafft haben. Ich wäre aber auch sehr froh, in 20 Jahren nicht in einer dystopischen Sci-Fi-Zukunft aufzuwachen, wo er alles verloren ist.
Puh, na ich hoffe, wir schaffen das noch. Ich habe noch eine kleine Detailfrage, die ich euch zum Abschluss stellen möchte. Und das ist, ich habe jetzt, weil jetzt immer, es kam jetzt dieser Schere im Kopfbegriff. Also es gibt schon Überwachung und deswegen gibt es die Schere im Kopf. Und im Chat zur Sendung hat gerade jemand gesagt, na er hätte die schon bei sich. Entdeckt ihr das bei euch auch? Dass ihr schon, dass ihr manchmal denkt, okay, das könnte jetzt irgendwo auftauchen. Und wenn ja, was würdet ihr empfehlen, wie man damit umgeht? Soll man dann das wirklich verbergen und der Schere stattgeben und sagt so, nee, jetzt erst recht, ich mache es trotzdem. Oder gerade deswegen?
Jetzt erst recht.
Also wenn wir unsere Freiheiten nicht ausleben, dann werden wir sie erst recht verlieren.
Na ich, das hat ja Linus vorhin schon angedeutet, ich habe das Problem mit der Überwachung schon ein bisschen länger und kenne diese Schere im Kopf auch ganz gut. Ich glaube, dieses einfach jetzt erst recht ist eigentlich die richtige Richtung. Aber das ist nicht immer so ganz einfach. Ich glaube, man muss ja am letzten Endes dann auch überlegen. Ich habe da kein Rezept zu. Aber es gibt sie und es ist, glaube ich, besser darüber nachzudenken, dass es sie gibt und wie wir mit ihr umgehen wollen, als einfach so zu tun, als gäbe es sie nicht. Und als kämen wir damit schon klar.
Ich glaube, wir dürfen uns von unseren Utopäen irgendwie nicht verabschieden und müssen halt steif gegenhalten.
Doch Revolution.
Dann danke ich euch, Linus, Andre und Anne, für diese Einblicke in zwei Jahren Snowden. Sehr interessant. Ihr könnt die Sendung auf jeden Fall auch noch als Podcast hören. Er scheint im Laufe der Nacht auf fritz.de, später dann auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Traditionell ist es so, dass am Ende der Sendung der Vertreter des Chaos Computer Clubs noch Termine ankündigt. Herr Neumann, hätten Sie da noch etwas für die geneigten Hörer?
Wir hätten da so eine Gulasch-Programmier-Nacht. Vom 4.6. bis 7.6. im Zentrum für Kunst- und Medientechnologie und der Hochschule für Gestaltung, beide ansässig in Karlsruhe. Die Gulasch-Programmier-Nacht wird ausgerichtet vom Entropia e.V. Das ist ein Erfahrungskreis des CCC in Karlsruhe ansässig. Dort gibt es Hackengulasch-Vorträge, Cloud sogar, Chunk-Workshops, Lounge-Mate und Spaß am Gerät. Ich habe gerade schon ein bisschen im Fahrplan gestöbert. Sieht interessant aus, viel Technik, viel Kultur. Denke ich auf jeden Fall eine Reise wert für diejenigen, die nicht ortsansässig sind. Und dann haben wir natürlich das Camp, das CCC Camp. Ich glaube, es ist vom 13. bis 17. offiziell. Ich werde da ein bisschen früher anreisen. August? August, genau. August. Da fahren wir dann alle auf den Acker, zelten und versuchen, uns vor dem bösen Stern am Himmel zu schützen, der unsere Haut verbrennt.
Wird es dort auch Internet geben?
Es wird dort Internet geben, es wird dort Schunk geben. Also Wasserversorgung müssen wir noch mal gucken.
Du wirst auch noch von den Demos sprechen, die es gibt jetzt, oder?
Nein, das machst ja dann du.
Weil Camp ist super und macht viel Spaß. Und vorher gibt es aber noch eine Reihe von Demonstrationen, unter anderem gegen den BND in Berlin diesen Samstag um 14 Uhr. Die Rechtsanwälte gegen Totalüberwachung am Kanzlerinamt um 16 Uhr. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wer genau am BND. Es gibt im Moment eine ganze Tour. Freiheit statt Angst, die durch verschiedene Städte tourt. In Frankfurt ist am Samstag auch eine Demo. Und es ist nicht so, dass nichts stattfinde. Geht hin und zeigt, dass ihr was dagegen habt.
Also man kann sie politisch engagieren und gleichzeitig Spaß haben. Dann nochmal vielen Dank. Ich wünsche euch eine gute Nacht. Um nur noch zu sagen, heute mehr denn je. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Lasst euch nicht überwachen. Und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.